[Music]
are you tired of cramped city living
then anti-gravity might be for you do
you want to soar effortlessly over
traffic jams while other drivers below
you lose their minds
then anti-gravity might be for you we
haven't exactly perfected the technology
yet but if we do it would completely
revolutionize our world how can it
change the way we build cities why would
it allow us to travel further into space
and how could it help us colonize alien
planets this is what if and here's what
would happen if we could create
anti-gravity according to NASA gravity
is the force by which a planet or other
body draws objects toward its center we
really don't know why gravity behaves
this way we just know that it does and
that's about all we need to know this
video and hey while we're on the topic
of things we don't know everything about
let's bring antigravity into the mix
anti-gravity as the name suggests is a
hypothetical means of counteracting the
effects of gravity now while a lot of
scientists say that's impossible it's
not stopping us from trying but if we're
ever going to figure it out we're going
to have to delve into an even more
mysterious part of our universe
antimatter to understand what antimatter
is and what it has to do with
anti-gravity we're going to have to
travel back in time to the Big Bang when
the Big Bang
happened it created matter and
anti-matter matter is made up of atoms
the building blocks of chemical elements
such as helium oxygen and hydrogen
inside atoms you'll find particles such
as protons which have a positive
electrical charge and electrons which
usually have a negative charge for
antimatter the electrical charge of
these particles is reversed this has led
to some speculation that other
properties would be reversed - such as
the way they react to gravity we haven't
been able to test how antimatter reacts
to gravity yet still some theories say
that when we do we'll find that
antimatter particles fall up instead of
down giving us our first real-life
example of anti-gravity if this is the
case it could lead to a scientific and
technological revolution we could
theoretically use the antimatter to
develop technology that shields people
or objects from gravitational forces in
other words we could make a lot of stuff
float in midair so what would we do with
this crazy technology well first up
would have to be hoverboards right
and no I'm not talking these things I'm
talking real hoverboards that don't
touch the ground we could even create
hover boots to help with our slam dunk
game and flying cars to help with our
morning commute
we could build floating cities to
accommodate our ever-expanding
population massive structures could be
suspended over bodies of water or rocky
terrains where we wouldn't otherwise be
able to build but maybe we see the
biggest implications of anti-gravity
technology when we look even further up
to the Stars space travel would become a
lot safer and a lot less expensive our
spacecraft wouldn't need rocket fuel to
launch out of our atmosphere instead we
could just stop gravity from affecting
them
anti-gravity wouldn't only help us get
to space it could also help us find a
new home out there we'd no longer have
to worry about planets having gravity
too strong for human habitation since we
could just use anti-gravity to shield
ourselves from it yeah we realize that
there's a lot of unknowns and
hypotheticals with this one but hey
that's what happens when we're talking
about something as mysterious as
antimatter if you think this stuff is
crazy just wait until I tell you about
dark matter but that's a story for
another what if